[Musique]
alors je vais vous parler d'un endroit
que vous connaissez bien vous y allez
certainement régulièrement
peut-être même que vous y habitez et
pourtant c'est un endroit dans lequel il
n'est pas facile de vivre cet endroit
c'est david
pourquoi c'est difficile aujourd'hui
d'habiter en ville
pourquoi faut être résistants quand on
habite en ville les villes ça émet des
gaz à effet de serre et de la pollution
atmosphérique et la pollution lumineuse
et de la pollution sonore et donc c'est
pas facile de vivre en ville cette photo
que j'ai prise l'année dernière en chine
ça montre à quel point ça peut être
compliqué de vivre en ville on pourrait
se dire ce dommage de ne pas avoir pris
une photo un jour il faisait beau fait
ce jour là il faisait beau et donc ce
jour là où il faisait beau haouran
petite bourgade de 10 millions
d'habitants
vous n'avez jamais entendu parler mais
l'agglo ne fait que 30 millions
d'habitants donc c'est normal que vous
ne connaissiez pas ce jour là en fait le
soleil ils étaient là comme un espèce de
halo qui nous a gentiment passer dans le
ciel
et pourquoi on le voyait pas parce que
la concentration de polluants a atteint
des niveaux très importants
nous on a un seuil d alerte à partir de
70 microgrammes par mètre cube 70
microgrammes par mètre cube
c'est finalement le degré poison à
partir duquel on considère que là il
faut faire attention
ce jour là on est aux alentours de 250
300 mon record personnel en chine
450 ce jour j'en avais achetés les
masques quand même le record en chine
c'est parfois plus de 1000 par x 1200
pour vous rendre compte il ya eu un jour
où l'air était tellement pollué qui est
un immeuble qui a pris feu il est
évident
en fait personne s'en aperçut ce qu'on
pouvait pas distinguer la fumée de
l'incendié de la pollution
alors évidemment on n'en est pas là mais
en même temps l'actualité de cette
semaine
j'aurais pu prendre une photo similaire
à paris à lyon à bordeaux avec un beau
nuage de pollution et les territoires de
demain pour qu'il soit résilient il faut
les imaginer
il faut les envisager il faut lé design
et pour qu'ils puissent offrir une
résistance une résilience notamment au
changement climatique qui s'opère alors
évidemment les urbanistes des
architectes les collectivités locales
avec lesquelles on travaille tous on
essaie de réfléchir et de se dire quelle
solution va pouvoir proposer donc déjà
on va regarder un peu ce qui se fait
alors il ya des solutions un petit peu
folle il ya un artiste chinois qui
s'appelle wang wenzhang qui s'est baladé
avec son aspirateur
il a aspiré l'air puisqu'il a récupéré
dans son ère il en a fait des briques il
ya même un autre artiste qu'on a fait
des diamants mais bon ça ça suffit pas
il ya une designeuse hollandaise qui
s'est dit on va filtrer l'air on va
mettre des grosses pompes qui vont
filtrer l'air on va enlever toutes ces
particules et comme ça on va dépolluer
la ville on à l'université de calgary
qui a imaginé des pièges aux gaz à effet
de serre pour que la ville n'émettent
plus et gaz à effet de serre et donc on
va les piéger avant qu'il soit parti la
municipalité de pékin qui a connu
l'année dernière 175 jours de très
fortes pollutions à l imaginer des
grands ventilateurs qui pourrait comme
ça souffle et la pollution et l'enlever
de la vie alors nous en france on s'est
dit c'est solution c'est intéressant
mais le problème c'est que ces solutions
elles consomment de l'énergie et elles
vont finalement participé aux problèmes
qu'elles vont engendrer
évidemment il ya une réflexion à avoir
sur comment en baisse ses émissions ces
polluants mais il ya aussi des outils et
donc on a cherché un outil qui soit
finalement un outil de notre temps los
teques puisque l'impact
les appareils électroniques est
important qu'ils consomment peu ou pas
d'énergie du coup on a cherché un outil
qui fonctionne à l'énergie solaire et un
peu d'eau on s'est dit qu'il fallait que
ce soit un outil des connectés
smartphones les mises à jour du firmware
tout ça c'est trop compliqué un outil
déconnecté et puis on s'est dit bon
c'est 2016 il faut également qu'on
trouve un outil sans gluten alors cet
outil je n'ai pas amené avec moi mais je
vous propose de le voir en oeuvre il est
là parce que c'est la voiture qui va
être électrique est ce que c'est le
smart grid qui va être cachés sous la
voirie et qu'on n'imagine pas non vous
l'avez compris c'est tout il a toujours
été là et en fait on a oublié qu'il
était là l'outil dont je veux parler
c'est évidemment cet arbre parce que cet
arbre aujourd'hui les villes les
architectes et urbanistes et ingénieurs
le on le voit comme quelque chose
d'ornement talent sais pas si vous avez
déjà vu le design d'un quartier mais un
arbre c'est des revers qu'on va poser
comme ça sur sur autocad on va poser ses
roues verts pour qui on est un petit peu
partout or cet arbre aujourd'hui il faut
dépasser c'est sa fonction ornementale
dire que cet arbre là on n'en a pas
conscience mais il nous rend un maximum
de services tout à l'heure quand vous
sortirez avant de rentrer chez vous vous
poserez la question de cet arbre là que
vous verrez
quelles sont les fonctions qu'ils vous
proposent mais ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
les services écosystémiques les services
rendus par la nature est donc cet arbre
il a beaucoup d'atouts
ils stockent le carbone il des polluent
l'air ils aident à lutter contre ce
qu'on appelle les îlots de chaleur
urbains le fait qu'en ville il fait très
chaud
saviez vous qu'un arbre ça équivaut à 5
climatiseurs
cet arbre et la même d'autres vertus
qu'on n'imagine pas si jamais vous êtes
malade
une étude qui montre que si votre
fenêtre donne sur un arbre vous avez
plus de chances de guérir il a enfin une
étude
deux chercheurs de l'illinois qui montre
que quand on plante des arbres dans la
ville
sa baisse même la criminalité donc
vraiment ça dépasse le cadre qu'on
connaît alors quand on évoque sa sur des
projets sur lesquels on travaille
souvent les villes nous disent oui mais
bon ça coûte de l'argent il faut lé
planté il faut les entretenir
voilà on a un contexte économique est
compliqué comment faire la réponse
et voilà quand j'ai investi 1 $ dans un
arbre
ça me rapporte 5,6 dollars ça c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est la ville de new
york
alors imaginez si même les américains
nous disent que les arbres sont
rentables c'est vraiment qu'on peut y
aller et donc c'est l'idée de se dire
que ce qui est invisible apporte des
services à la ville apporte des services
aux territoires et demain on va se
servir de ces outils là comme des outils
pour rendre les territoires résignant
donc c'est vraiment important de changer
de paradigme
alors que faire évidemment il faut
planter des arbres la ville de new york
a associé ses citoyens pour planter un
million d'arbres et atteint ses
objectifs
une à deux années avant l'objectif
initial donc vous il faut vous battre
parce que vous n'imaginez pas à quel
point sur les projets d'urbanisme
il est tentant de supprimer les arbres
les ingénieurs se disent en couple
arbres aux normes et 1 c'est pareil je
suis ingénieur mais en fait l'arbre
mature il a mis du temps à être
complètement développé à acquérir ses
fonctions et donc remplacer un arbre par
un arbre ça fonctionne pas comme ça et
donc demain on va concevoir les
territoires on va aller jusqu'à choisir
les essences d'arbres en fonction des
services qu'on veut offrir
on va choisir à une licence qui va
dépolluer à côté d'une rue on va choisir
une essence qui va particulièrement bien
stocker le carbone ça ne nous privera
pas de réfléchir à comment baisser nos
émissions
mais en tout cas c'est une façon de
rendre à la nature sa place dans la vie
alors pour vous c'est pas facile de dire
quels arbres mais
compass en plantant un arbre antoine les
stresser j'imagine et j'ai croisé
antoine il est hyper stressée ça va pas
hyper stressée depuis une semaine
ah bon qu'est ce qui s'est passé il a
merdé sur un projet il a merdé
ah bon qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a
planté un arbre donc on se trompe pas
parce qu'un arbre le jour où il a
atteint toute sa fin de vie sert que
même quand l'arbre il en fin de vie
quand on n'a plus besoin de lui on va
pouvoir en faire plein de choses on va
pouvoir en faire du bois énergie on va
pouvoir en faire du bois de construction
on va valoriser l'ensemble de l'arbre
donc on imagine bien utiliser l'arbre
surtout son cycle de vie
il faut aller chercher des endroits où
planter des arbres dans les parcs les
jardins dans les rues et réfléchir à ça
il ya notamment une expérience en
amérique du nord qui est vraiment très
intéressante
l'écart non assez rigolo ça s'appelle
l'urbanisme par la neige
alors c'est vrai que nous avec le
changement climatique la neige c'est pas
toujours évident mais qu'est ce qui se
passe dans le cadre de l'urbanisme par
la neige
c'est simplement que là bas quand il
neige ça permet de voir où les voitures
parce qu'elle est finalement l'endroit
strictement nécessaire où elles ont
besoin d'aller et tous les endroits où
la neige n'est pas dégagé c'est
finalement des endroits qu'on peut
reconquérir et donc sur ces endroits
qu'on peut répondre guérir on plante des
arbres ont fait des pistes cyclables ont
fait du mobilier urbain ou une offre des
terrasses pour les restaurateurs et
finalement on reprend de l'espace urbain
au service de notre territoire
je vais simplement vous demandé
d'imaginer qu'on est de retour au début
des années 2000 internet haut débit
commence à vraiment se développer
le wifi arrive et imaginer que les
arbres diffuse le wifi mais on aurait
combien des arbres on aurait pu
certainement même un dans la pièce pour
vous puissiez sur vos smartphones
moi aussi il y aurait tellement d'arbres
plantés qu'on aura certainement sauver
le climat la biodiversité les villes et
tout ça ça serait magnifique
malheureusement ces arbres il diffuse
pas le wifi
ils produisent seulement l'oxygène dont
on a besoin pour vivre
[Applaudissements]